we have an update to a story that we  brought you a couple of weeks ago here  officer nicholas quintana and his wife  took in five children from foster care  after responding to a homicide call in  january well now the north las vegas  city council is honoring the family for  that selfless act  your willingness to step up  is i think we are put on this earth for  a purpose  and i think  god whether you believe or you don't  believe i think god has a charge for all  of us in this life and this is your  charge you stepped up to the plate and  you and your wife i think are just  angels from above  officer quintana has told 8 news now  that since his story was told he and his  family have been overwhelmed with  gratitude from the community support  that they have been receiving